it was a time of great hope
after months of violent protests that
left many killed
sudan's revolutions seemed to have
triumphed in april 2019.
the dictator amaril bashir was
overthrown
civilians were now sitting at the
negotiating table with the army generals
that had replaced al-bashir's government
after 30 years of authoritarian rule
civilians were getting a say in the
future of their country
[Music]
it was against this backdrop that we met
asil dieb
a sudanese artist who had returned from
the diaspora at the height of the
violent protest
her self-assigned mission was to keep
the memory of those who died seeking
freedom alive
she painted murals of them near the
houses of their families
the artwork being there is a reminder to
everyone that
you know they died for you we have to
remember the martyrs because
at the end of the day it all comes down
to they went out to protest
for us this art forces you to speak
about what's happening you know
today it's not just that specific person
but it what he died for and the cause
that he died for
now two years later aseal is
disappointed
the transitional government had promised
justice for the killed and injured
protesters
promises that have come to nothing say
the families of the victims
the martyrs are still trying to
look and find and get that justice i've
visited
uh so many of these uh families
the martial's families and they all say
the same thing there's
no justice there's no clarification of
how they're gonna get that justice and
when they're gonna get that justice so
things are very vague at this moment
they kind of gave up hope basically
there has been no contact from the
government
two years later calling these martyrs
families and saying
you know we're gonna get your rights by
you know
doing a hearing on this date or
compensating you on this way
the worsening economic situation is also
weighing on the lives of people in sudan
under bashir's rule the country was cut
off economically because of sanctions
the transitional government has
succeeded in removing sudan
from the united states's state sponsors
of terrorism list
that's paved the way for the country to
rejoin the global economy
the change is slow to reach the common
man
and like many countries around the world
the covet pandemic has hit sudan
very hard people are tired now
you know there's electricity cuts for
half of the day
there's no gas no petrols for their cars
people are just tired they're living day
by day i think you reach a point
in your life where you see that so much
time has passed that you just want to
let it go you know and you want to leave
despite the challenges asil is not
willing to give up on the promise of the
revolution
her latest project was a public mural
depicting the former dictator amir
bashir as the coronavirus
something that would have been
unthinkable under his rule
she says she wants to send a message to
her fellow countrymen and women with
this peace
just as we have beaten a dictator we can
beat the virus
and overcome anything
dwe's a ibrahim filed the report you
just saw and she joins me now in studio
good to see you ais so
uncomfortable living conditions the
rising price of bridge triggered the
sudan revolution has life improved for
the young people who took to the streets
you know christine nobody thought this
was easy even two years ago when i was
in khartoum at the height of the
euphoria
the young people there didn't strike me
as naive they knew the kind of mammoth
challenge that was facing their country
but at the same time two years later the
harsh living conditions are starting to
really take their toll and even the most
optimistic among them
are now you know feeling the brunt of
this you know remember this
this started as a protest against a hike
in the price of bread but in addition to
that there are the frustrations with the
political transitions
transition there are often times been
been this feeling that the military side
of the government is sort of co-opting
the power meant for the civilian
uh part of the government so the issue
of the kill protest is one thing
but things like the transitional
legislative council
that's behind you know this was the
legislative council that was supposed to
be put together
to represent sudan more widely and also
there's no constitutional
conference also as promised that is also
behind but there have been some
improvements in freedom of speech that
is something that i hear
time and time again that uh you know
that situation has improved and people
are able to express their frustrations
at least something
that was not the case under the bashir
right
women were at the forefront of the
revolution are women
better off in sudanese society today we
all remember the image of that young
sudanese woman on the car you know
chanting she became the symbol of
this revolution and certainly there have
been some improvement
uh you know in the situation of women
the first transitional cabinet
uh south sudan's first ever female
foreign
minister youth minister in the first
transitional cabinet there have been two
was also a woman female genital
mutilation has been
criminalized in sudan a challenge and a
demand by
feminist activists for years and also
some outdated laws about how women
should dress in public have also been
scrapped
but something that even asil told me you
know as a woman who's
you know her her job means that she has
to be outside you know this is a huge
taboo she says you know
even though there have been improvements
in these laws there's still the social
perception it's still for example
difficult for her to go
and you know do her murals so the laws
are taking steps
but social perception still has to be
changed
that's tw's a ibrahim thank you
[Music]
now in january the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres appointed folker pertes
as the new special representative for
sudan
uh mr pettis joins us now from cartoon
welcome to dw news africa
it has been two years since omar
al-bashir's ousted
have things improved for the people of
sudan since he left
well things have improved but challenges
remain
and the challenges are are enormous
things have improved on the peace front
as it were
things have improved as a political
transition front or track
but we still have economic problems so
actually
objections have become deeper and we
still have
tensions between different parts of the
population particularly in darfur
that have played out very very
dramatically and negatively
i do want to pick up on the point uh
that you're making about therefore there
has been recent
and race in in the region as you've been
saying and i'd like for our viewers
to hear one eyewitness account before i
ask you my next question
this is a large fire in abuja camp
it's a massive fire it will burn
everything
look at this fire sure
this is what sudan is going to be like
so so an eyewitness account from the
ground there dozens
have already died in inter-communal
violence many rebel groups
are not on board with that juba peace
agreement
um ambassador pettis how fragile is the
security situation in sudan
the situation in sudan and such is not
fragile that's a situation
in darfur and particularly africa is
extremely fragile
and what we have seen in the town of
genena
where your eyewitness uh is
and is reporting from we have seen it in
exactly that
town for the third time now in less
than a year and a half it's the same
constellation of inter-communal clashes
which a little bit less politely said
is glacier clashes between different
tribes it is about land rights it is
about
who is allowed to live where and to be
active in agriculture or have his words
where
it is also unfortunately about who is
getting aid from the international
community
um ambassador this violence in this in
in default region as you're saying it's
not a sudan problem
it's more a regional problem but it has
been linked to the withdrawal of u.n
peacekeeping forces
that were there was that a mistake by
by the u.n does the u.n need to
reconsider the decision
to withdraw those peacekeeping forces
from the region then
well i didn't take this decision
and the uni transmission wasn't involved
so
uh you would have to ask this question
to members of the security council who
took the decision so as a new u.n
mission what we can do
is we can support the sudanese
government and sudanese society
in becoming better on protecting
civilians but now it is clearly the
government responsibility
the government is realizing that this
responsibility
is huge some people as you rightly say
even governors in darfur are
not happy with the drawdown of younamit
but that decision has been taken and it
seems to be irreversible
ambassador going back to 2019
specifically remember the statement by
the u.n condemning the violence and
force that sudanese officials
had used against protesters dozens of
people were killed
and and as we've been listening to to
young people in our report
no one's been brought to account for
that have you raised this matter in your
engagements
with the people in charge of sudan right
now
we are discussing these matters all the
time yes we are in contact with the
government we are in contact with the
with the legal authorities here um what
we insist upon when we speak about these
issues
is that rule of law should be applied
dually i mean it's not about simply
putting people
in prison and actually there are a
couple of these
perpetrators or suspected perpetrators
in prison right now
um but what is more important from your
own perspective is
that even suspected perpetrators of this
kind of atrocities
will be brought to a legal court
procedure
and proper rule of law will be applied
and that is indeed what we are talking
about
on that note ambassador sorry if i may
interrupt you there on that note i i
want to interrupt you there because
the government the sudanese government
has pardoned a former member of the
janjaweed militia
who the u.n sanctioned for alleged
atrocities in darfur
are pardons uh that are pardons that
conducive to to peace and reconciliation
in sudan
well it's a very delicate measure uh
matter is this this person who was
pardoned
was actually not imprisoned for the
atrocities
he allegedly was part of and he has been
sanctioned
for advising by the united nations he
was
he was imprisoned for his role in a
conflict between government forces and
his own ones
now i think that this person being on
the u.n sanctions list
it is the right decision not to remove
him from
this list so we still expect the
sudanese government
to work together with the united nations
and with the icc
here and hand over suspected persons to
the isis
to the international community
ambassador
what needs to happen next in the region
well if you ask for the region there are
a couple of other issues we have these
tensions between ethiopia and sudan
and we can only and we do ask everybody
to de-escalate
and not further escalate not even
rhetorically
the situation between the sudan and
ethiopia it spoke about
border issues as well as
the dam that is being built in
ethiopia and raises some concern in the
downstream countries particularly here
in sudan but also
in egypt in sudan there is a clear
agenda
of how to move forward on the next step
according to the agenda which the
sudanese said themselves since our
constitutional declaration after the
revolution
is to appoint a transitional legislative
council
so as to have more legitimacy and more
participation more inclusivity
when it comes to taking uh important
decision
then constitutional conversations have
to start
uh very importantly in order to have a
constitution in place before the
elections
at the end of the transition period and
the third
enormously important political step is
here to start
peace negotiations with parties
hold out groups as some people say who
have not signed up
to see juba peace agreement of last year
and that is the un invoice to sudan
ambassador for competes
talking to us from khartoum thank you
thank you very much